michael
5k means five kilometers not 5 000 miles
man
hey hey oh my god what are you doing you
said come in no i didn't just oh my god
please
he's leaving our plan worked we saved
our own honeymoon and fun bonus we
cheered up holt yes okay it's time to
celebrate you know what that means this
bee needs a c in her a oh my god this
babe needs a coconut in her arms oh
i thought you were saying this music
oh my god yeah that was my reaction all
right i'll go get us a couple of coke
i'm gonna go powder my nose amongst
other things
if you know what i mean
she gonna powder her vagina you gotta
help me man let's hear it for the boss
wow that was as long as it was loud oh
me home dumpling
it's betty time ah hey ben you like star
trek talk about that for a little bit
they're making a sequel
i'm assuming with the same alternate
timeline but if jj abrams and company
expect us to believe that it's spock
with the romantic tension with ahura and
not kirk well let's just say the message
boards are going nuts
i want to take you both home and
bend you over and just
at the same time
well i'm going to raise the stakes
i want you to watch this
and i want you to burn this into your
brains
because this is an image
then i want you people to remember for a
long time to come
whenever you come into the office i want
you to think about this we don't need to
yes we do what
oh
i did it
thank you
thank you thank you see
i'm still here
we're all still here
oh come on dwight come on man the math
thing isn't the problem night shift's
keeping you and kevin apart you two just
need a bone
what did you say don't say it again i
said you two need a bone
how
dare you detective diaz i am your
superior officer
what happens in my bedroom detective is
none of your business bone
don't ever speak to me like that again
why did you do that dude his pen up now
he knows problem solved
what do you say we
consummate our relationship
tonight
huh
let's
do it
and the last card is played what are you
doing shh this is a library you see
what's happening here ron i need that
crotch blinder no you don't just end it
look at my boobs no look downstairs no
there's a prize inside for you it's over
tammy
what
to hell with you woman goodbye
how dare you are you kidding me you'll
be back they all come back well done
jeremy
turns out the crotch blinder was inside
you all along
i want to get it on i'm naked
what's happening
oh some guy exposed himself to phyllis
in the parking lot
really is she okay
yeah bob vance took her for a walk to
calm down
okay
phyllis you say
hmm
what is so funny
um
i mean did he even see pam
or uh karen from behind
i'm guessing not
i'm sorry
it's pretty funny when you think about
it oh not really no it's disgusting and
demeaning oh okay
masters of comedy a guy dropped his
pants have you ever been to the circus
okay
he's back
[Applause]
hey what's going on there's a police car
in them
what oh
[Music]
what's going on oh phyllis got flashed
it's um
i don't think laughing about its
appropriate response oh come on we are
laughing at phyllis but she's not even
here so no harm no vowel
don't think the women in this office
incidentally where were you during all
of this maybe you're the flasher or is
it a parent teacher conference uh-huh
prove it let's see your penis
i
you know
as that was coming out of my mouth
i knew that it was wrong
okay you ready mm-hmm
hello oh my god are you melville dewey
indeed i am
i invented the dewey decimal system but
right now i'm working on
the do me decimal system mm-hmm yeah
this is really working for me really
yeah awesome so mr dewey can you save me
from the terrorists that have taken over
nakatomi plaza yes holly gennaro
i just need to file them in the library
card catalog yeah this is really hard to
track let's just take our clothes off oh
thank god this old jacket is so hot yeah
it's really good to see you ron
you've aged horribly
are you
the son of a [ __ ]
oh my god what is your problem nothing's
changed has it he set the bed on fire
excuse me i did okay is that what you
wanted
we're fine we're fine please
take it easy
when you meddle in someone's personal
life it's just so
rewarding
oh yes baby
[Laughter]
defcon 20.
she wants to get back together what are
you going to do i don't know that's why
you're here help me you want to get back
together no
no
what do i do
just don't get back together with her
what if she makes me how can she make
you get back together she made me do a
lot of things i didn't want to do this
was a terrible relationship you were not
happy when you were with her i wasn't
you're so much happier now
just go in there and be strong you're
right
you are absolutely right i need to go in
there and tell her that we can't be
together right
wow do it i'm in a very good place right
now
thank you
okay
jan
we need to talk
janna's in a different place right now
and it is a sign of maturity to give
people second chances
so i'm going to hear her out
you